this is a glimpse into the world of
radicalization the young man in the
headscarf appears to carry out a mock
execution in another image as if firing
a gun there's a young child in front of
him by the time his family discovered
these photographs on a computer Ali
calendar had gone to Syria to fight for
Islamic state Sky News has been given
the previously unseen pictures by Ali's
family taken at a place where they
thought he was attending religious
teachings it was from this area of
Coventry in the West Midlands that Ali
and two friends left for Syria two years
ago a city their Afghan and Kurdish
families made their homes and where they
hoped their children would be safe in
reality it's thought the teenagers were
brainwashed into fighting for is within
their own community Sky News recently
obtained thousands of the terror groups
recruitment files including those of Ali
Callen tar Rashida Marnie and Mohammad
Hadi the files shed new light on the
last movements of the three boys and why
they wanted to go to Syria and Rashid
said he wanted to be a fighter for
Islamic stays Shirin Ali was a close
friend of Rashid Imani we showed him
Rasheed's registration form in which the
youngster told is he wanted to join in
the role not of suicide bomber but as a
fighter a declaration which clashes with
the 19 year old Sharon knew I love
Russia like my brother I love him like
the good friend
it's nice guy he's normal guy did he
ever talk about Islamic snow never never
and did he change before he went no I
assume legs
one week before his left and he seemed
nothing this is the life Rashid enjoyed
the business student was known at this
Coventry shisha bar and restaurant there
was never any talk of an ambition to
become a jihadist the life he lived
right up until he went to Syria was a
world away from the strict ideals of
Islamic state did he wear normal clothes
and he had a girlfriend yeah he's a good
friend
British girlfriend even when one day
that I'm coming to eat I see that you
have a nice different hi my name is
Rashid ammonia I'm 12 years old I'm
playing Red Wing
hello my name is Alec a little traffic
and a free lift back both Rashida Marnie
and Ally Colin tar are now thought to be
dead targeted and killed in drone
strikes in Syria and Iraq from a young
age the boys bonded through football a
small friendship cluster manipulated by
extremists within the community they
left behind there are concerns that not
enough has been done to prevent the
radicalization of more teenagers many of
the people we've spoken to say
radicalization has been driven
underground making it much more
difficult to prevent even within the
Muslim community raising suspicions
about who can be trusted I know one
could dish family they took their kids
out of the school now their mother
teaching them and that's hundred-person
I agree with that things has changed
this seems like mosque has changed
through from a prayer place into a kind
of scary group of criminals I would say
it's not radical because killing people
no God will ask you for that it's
thought the third teenager 18 year old
Muhammad Hadi
seen here in glasses pictured with Ali
calendar is still alive and still
fighting for Islamic state a friend of
Muhammad says others remain vulnerable
it's a very dangerous thing and we got
you know got a lot of Muslims in this
country allow youth and we need to
tackle this problem before these people
get to their heads actually you know
radicalize them to travel to Syria none
of the boys were prepared to say on
their recruitment files who sponsored
them which is troubling for their
families who say the teenagers were so
well groomed they hid their conversion
until it was too late by then the three
teenagers had become signed up fighters
for Islamic state Lisa Holland skinny's
Coventry